hey everybody and welcome to an
unbelievable wild ride with stevo gosh i
just learned so much from some of our
guests
like mark cuban he got me in the nft
game
and if you want to see my very first nft
go to my instagram right now and that'll
show you where to find it
but i digress this week's episode
taught me the importance of hustling man
i think i'm going to try to start
working a lot harder
because this guy did what 800
daily vlogs sheesh he really benefited
from it too
very wise man very great episode let's
check it out
we are good to go man i'll [ __ ] dive
right in are you
rolling all these cameras are going
they're going you remotely operate these
things no i just i just went there and
did it
wow i was sneaky ladies and gentlemen
casey neistat yeah dude
dude it's it's cool to be in your van
and i've never said that to another
grown man before
that's cool i love it daisy you've met
scott randolph and paul briskey
what's up casey the team good to see you
guys i feel like i like the glasses and
i like your mustache so i'm gonna copy
you
you got sunglasses on too it looks like
ah they're just
uh transitions um but yeah dude thank
you for doing this man i i sl
slid into your dm to try to make it
happen and and
uh [ __ ] i love that dude i really
appreciate it and i also love that
here we are parked at the beach because
you've become just so
passionate about surfing yeah right you
gotta we've
dm we had a pretty extensive dm dialogue
about surfing
we did but i you know for me it's like
i i left new york city because i wanted
to figure out how to like
relax a little bit in life you know like
turn off that 24-hour day work work work
like hustler mentality
right and like surfing is such a
[ __ ]
thing where it's like when you're out in
the middle of the ocean you can't have a
camera with you or even your phone with
you
so it's like you don't have to guess
like am i doing this for work or social
media like am i doing this for reasons
other than i want to do it and the
answer is like
no so kind of all i do now is like surf
and hang out with my kids
do you ever like wish because you catch
a good wave you're like [ __ ] i wish i
had that on camera
yeah but like i've seen video of my
really good waves
and in my head i'm like kelly [ __ ]
slater
right and then when i see the video it's
so embarrassing
yeah i know it's that like i prefer to
just live with it in my head this
beautiful vision of me like
ducking into like a double overhead
barrel rather than having to confront
the fact that it's really just like
an ankle biter wave that i'm standing on
a wave storm as it like washes over my
feet
but uh yeah but but we both managed to
get barreled at kelly slater's surface
but you've like seen the videos like
jamie o'brien with like a six-year-old
girl on the same
[ __ ] surfboard going so deep in that
barrel
and then you're out there like a
grown-ass capable man
and i can't get near it right yeah that
was the first trip
second trip i got it well we just got
back from alaska and he got a couple
waves out there
that looked cold yeah dude thank you for
watching the video i don't know how you
like that seizing up that your lungs
does when you jump in the water
yeah i mean when i jumped in butt naked
it did shock the system but what's so
incredible about the technology of
wetsuits is that
like it felt no different than surfing
in california when you were fully suited
up when we were
full wetsuits hood gloves booties
what about when you were like sitting
waiting for a wave
it's surprisingly warm oh yeah
surprisingly the feet
get cold a little after a while but
right but
i was out there for like two hours three
hours like yeah didn't catch crazy
that was my first time trying to surf in
alaska in a lab
that felt appropriate to you yeah it
worked it worked for me
yeah oh man it was it was just a blast
dude and then surfing was easy
um but yeah dude i think um as far as
serpent goes and i'm gonna take this
right into the idea of like
of of a work ethic because that's i
think
there's a lot that's impressive about
you but but surfing's just
[ __ ] thankless to me man like it's so
hard it's so demanding it's like i do it
largely just because uh
i feel like the exercise is important
and it's like sort of a fun way to
exercise
but dude like i i hate it as much as i
love it
you ever see that netflix series called
cheer about like the hardcore
cheerleaders
i did it i think my girls okay it's
amazing it's about the best like
acrobatic cheerleaders in the world
these are like olympic level
athletes and what they're doing is so
complex and so difficult but what
took me about that show was how like
this
the squad the cheer squat how much they
supported one another
like we're trying to do something that's
so hard here and if you [ __ ] up
i got you i'm here to support you i'm
here to help you i'm here to elevate you
i thought you're gonna say
if you [ __ ] up it's gonna break my neck
the distinction i'm trying to draw here
is like surfing two
is like the hardest [ __ ] thing in the
world but imagine
trying to learn how to be the best
trailer instead of having your whole
surfs your cheer squad sure you on
imagine having them when you just be
like [ __ ] you you don't belong here
locals only [ __ ] right off the
map that's my [ __ ] wave
right exactly and to me like the zero to
one in surfing is harder than any sport
i've ever tried and i'm like a total
like my whole life i've been doing
athletics i'm a super fit
super athletic guy there's nothing i've
ever done that's had a harder
zero to one than surfing you want to go
snowboarding never been on a snowboard
in your life
end of the [ __ ] day you'll be able to
sketch your way down a green
and you'll be fine right oh yeah you
want to surf like six months later
you're gonna be able to stand up on
whitewash
right yeah yeah exactly or you might die
yeah you might drown like it's gonna be
one of those two
surfing is such [ __ ] [ __ ] in that
capacity and the whole time you're
learning
there's like a bunch of [ __ ]
intimidating bros in the lineup yelling
at you for doing
everything wrong yeah humiliating you
yeah that's a great point and you're at
the mercy of the
weather whether there's waves even if
there's waves maybe it's too windy like
on top of that just to get to the beach
in la
you know it's like an hour [ __ ] drive
to get there and then
you got to put on your wetsuit it's like
a really like just putting on a wetsuit
and taking off a wetsuit
is like an olympic sport it's hard yeah
that's what i learned
trying to serve i didn't learn how to
surf but like yeah putting on a wetsuit
is hard really hard right and taking it
off
it's it's so it's overall it's
[ __ ] and you just sit there like
i'm thinking i hate this i hate this why
i'm giving it up i'm giving up and then
you catch that one wave you know you're
on it for like three seconds and you're
like
yes uh-huh you're just paddling back
smiling like oh dude i can do this all
day
you're like i'm a god right i am a god
water conquering god so yes sir um
i i feel like you know in in many
respects
surfing represents for you kind of being
like deliberate about
like you just said you know uh turning
off that workaholic
kind of hustle mentality yeah you know
so
i lived in europe for 20 years and like
i moved to new york
with nothing like as close to homeless
as you could be at a three-month sublet
that was it and i had no money no job
was that still in high school uh i
dropped out of high school but that's
how old i was a teenager yeah i was i
think it was 19 when i moved to the city
okay um moved to the city from virginia
from connecticut uh how are you in
virginia like
less than a year yeah so if we're
backing up even further even further
you know i left home when i was 15 and i
moved to virginia
because like my brother lived there the
only place i could think of to go so i
like ran away from
home moved to virginia but then like
immediately knocked up
this girlfriend of mine and then moved
back to connecticut and had a baby
and then when she dumped me i was like
[ __ ] it and then i moved to new york
city
with nothing and like 20 years later
like really successful everything's
great
and my wife and i have two babies now
and my son's grown and it's like
we have to leave the city because i'm
such like a crazy workaholic
that there's no way for me to turn this
off right and that was the plan like
move to los angeles and figure out how
to chill out and like enjoy life and do
all those things and
i tried to do it in new york and like my
last year there was really miserable
because i wasn't able to i equate it to
like imagine lebron retiring from
basketball
but he still sits in at every game in
uniform with a ball in his hands
like that's what being in new york and
trying to slow down felt like
but did you feel like that because
you're doing daily vlogs
no i felt like that this was after i
stopped that this was just like my last
year there
it felt like that because i only knew
one version of new york like you only
have one
relationship with that city for me and
that relationship over the course of 20
years was like go [ __ ]
go and i tried to turn that off it's
like um
you know it's like having a serious
relationship and then deciding to just
be friends and think you can hang out
and it's going to be the same
it wasn't the same like i instead of
loving this city i [ __ ] hated it
i was like what am i doing here i hate
all this right so i
yeah that's why i ran away to los
angeles and like surfing for me is the
ultimate
stupid indulgence it's definitely stupid
would you go back to new york and visit
or you're just over it forever
okay so oh you're moving back yeah
okay it's like a toxic relationship dude
yeah
no here's the thing here's the thing
about la
it sucks so i want to go back to new
york dude i love
l.a yeah i don't think anything sucks
about it except maybe the traffic
here's the reason why i think it sucks
and this starts to get into like my own
psychotic
it sucks for one reason it's
not new york city
and no matter what this place does still
not new york city but have you been back
to new york to even see if you like it i
don't need to
i like know what that city is and like
look nothing i'm saying here is rational
none of this makes sense this is just
like like i i don't know if like this is
um
socially appropriate to say and if it
isn't or this is offensive i apologize
but i say this with
full reverence i don't say this as a
joke i identify
as a new yorker like
and what that means is like i feel like
a [ __ ] interloper here in l.a like i
don't feel like i belong
it's been two years two and a half years
i've made friends
i embrace this place i go for hikes
every day i run every day i'm
outside every day i surf like it's going
out of stock like
i have embraced this place and i just
like i feel like i
don't fit in i feel like i did before i
moved to new york city where like this
is fine this just isn't my home like
this isn't right
so but i read about you that you were
married you got
divorced and then you married your wife
again right so it's kind of like the new
york relationship well we got it
annulled
okay you got the divorce and old or the
the marriage okay
see we got i'm seeing a pattern here
you're probably gonna it's gonna be the
best thing ever [ __ ] time around the
wife it was like mashed potatoes and
gravy man we figured it out
right so maybe like living in la for
these two and a half years
when you go back like it do you think
that's gonna help you sort of
find a healthier balance in new york
well like okay so i don't know
what if this is just me rationalizing
nonsense in my head
so it will make sense but my general
thesis here
is that like you know sometimes no
matter how many times you hit the reset
on your like nintendo entertainment
center it just
system it just doesn't work until you
turn it off all the way or you unplug
the [ __ ] thing
like i had to unplug and i did it's been
two and a half years outside that city
we're not going anywhere for a while
kids enrolled in school here we just
signed a lease but like
i got new york in the crosshairs i want
to go back same
same borough i mean i want to live in
the same building
i'm not even joking but i have this like
i'm just like [ __ ]
i have these like what is it like
delusions of grandeur like
i have this have my cake you need it to
plan which is like
i'm gonna keep my truck in new york city
and my surfboards and like
jersey has great surfing like you know
ben gravy
i don't ben gravy is like this epic
surfer out of
um new jersey like lives in what's it
called that place where trump had his
atlantic city
that's what the casinos were right
atlantic city is like amazing surf
yeah so i have this idea and i might be
just crazy i'm pretty sure i'm wrong
about it but i think i'll be able to
pull it off
where i can live in new york city and
have like a slower life like i do here
but be in the city where i feel like i
belong
it will never it'll never happen i can
see it happening in new jersey
you're close enough right i'm still
gonna try
good i'm struck by the way that you
apologized
in advance of saying that you love new
york city and
and feel that out of place in l.a i
don't think there's anything
controversial about that statement and i
also think it's really remarkable that
for for the research that i did
to prepare for this i i
it seemed that the most controversial
moment of your career
was um like publicly endorsing
hillary clinton and uh you're making
some completely
objective statements about why it would
be an awful
uh reality for donald trump to take
power
yeah that was like a really difficult
three years of waiting to tell her to
say i told you so
but yeah that was especially like with
all these youtubers being canceled as of
late
and youtube was getting in real trouble
it forced me to kind of look back at my
tenure on
youtube and like one i'm super thankful
that like i was just a married guy
with kids yeah like that kept me out of
so much [ __ ]
and then also like it's difficult
because like i'm friends a lot of these
youtubers who are in
a world of [ __ ] because of they're being
cancelled for things that
are in a lot of cases legitimate like
they you know
wrongdoing has transpired but when i
think back to when i was their age
like when i was in my early 20s when i
was in my late teens and like
my [ __ ] heroes were these [ __ ] on
this show on mtv called jackass
like that's all i wanted to be it was
like the path to success for me is how
destructive and sensational can i be and
like
i did a lot of really stupid [ __ ]
first off thank you for for the kind
words
and uh i don't know if that's accurate
man my sense of uh
of your you know
your career was just the idea of just
having a camera in my hand like doing
you know
your first video was like of your son
you know going to the zoo like
there was like uh and and
congratulations to
on being the the
singular reason for
the word viral video how about that like
it was and
it wasn't even you that came up with the
word it was was it the new york times
um washington post washington post i
think i don't know if that's been
validated but
it's such a good story that i will just
continue to tell it
yeah i mean at the washington post in
i think that was when the term viral
video was coined
about that video that my brother made
yeah
a secret ipod's dirty secret about how
they they had an
internal battery which they would refuse
to replace
so they their idea was okay cool our
battery dies
after 18 months that was casey's
experience yeah
and then people are gonna be they're
gonna be like man [ __ ] my battery died
they're gonna buy a new ipod casey took
exception to that
he said hey uh replace my [ __ ]
battery
ed calls them up right and they said ah
now you're gonna buy a new ipod
yeah rub me the wrong way yeah
and um and and this was like he said
2003 two years before
youtube came out and there were six
million views
of his ipod video called ipod's dirty
secret
but what i want to know is how how are
those six million views tabulated
if the way that the video is viral so to
speak was just through email
yeah so like um we had a page
counter that would flip every time
someone
clicked on the play button on the
quicktime
okay like the most basic splash page
possible i remember that
that makes perfect this is a single page
that had one video centered
and the you could click refresh and it
wouldn't move
the counter forward but if you click
play it would move the counter forward
you could juke that by watching it 10
times in a row right but like
whatever if our margins are still small
like that's
it it had like a really big impact
socially like in the world so whatever
the number was it like that movie
really went kind of gangbusters that was
the first thing that my brother van and
i were ever kind of recognized for
sure and then that led to the series on
hbo
yeah which uh and i heard two versions
i heard that the guy who who uh you know
sort of greenlit the project to begin
with funded it all himself
and then i heard that uh when hbo
bought it that they gave you two million
bucks
but i gotta believe that a large portion
of that two million bucks was just
to go and and recoup for the guy who
invested in it yeah i mean i can give
you specific numbers but it was like
so the guy who invested in it was a guy
named tom scott
who's a fascinating guy he like his sort
of
early success his biggest success was
after i think it was after high school
he went like his parents like used to do
their summers in nantucket and
massachusetts you know a little island
there
for rich people and he would paddle
around in a rowboat to all the yachts
and
sell the people on the boats fresh juice
that him and his buddy would make in a
blender
he turned that into a company called
nantucket nectar's
oh wow yeah dude which he sold to i
think ocean spray for
i don't know how much but like lots like
maybe tens or maybe
low 100 million like that kind of number
and then after that he just kind of did
really interesting media projects like
started a small sort of cable news cable
access channel
and we met him through a friend and we
did some fun video like projects
for him with him and then he's like i
want to do something big
and i think he thought like a feature
film and we're like no just like
bankroll us for a year
and in that year we'll make something
good like we didn't know what it was but
we just knew we didn't know how to make
a [ __ ] feature film
and so he agreed to that and i think
like it was around 300
000 so 300 000 is like whatever 25 grand
a month and i think that's what we asked
for if you give us 25 grand
a month we can have this done in a year
and we didn't know what this was and he
said yes
and like that's an insane amount of
money like my brother vanda i figured
out like that covers all of our bills
and we have like 18 grand or something
a month to just spend on making videos
like it was the biggest
most insane windfall we could ever
imagine and we spent
every cent of it just like making little
videos and when we meet with him
for our checkup like every two months we
just show him all these little videos
he just kept saying keep going keep
going keep going epic
and then after yeah like an amazing
believer and supporter and then after
like
nine months or so we had all this work
we showed it to
a guy named doug lyman was a big famous
like movie director like he directed
um born identity right and he directed
swingers was like his first feature
at that point was it all broken into the
you know the eight episodes no and
that's where doug comes and doug comes
in and watches
all of it and we're so intimidated
because he's like such a [ __ ] big
deal guy
he doesn't show a lot of emotion he
watched it he looks at us and he's like
this is a tv show
turn all those into 22 minute episodes
and we're like oh [ __ ]
all right and that's what we did we just
kind of strung them all together and put
an intro and an outro at the end of it
we called it a tv show
and then yeah we shopped it sold to hbo
for 2 million bucks and like
the deal with tom is he'd get his money
back and then his money back again
so it's like he gets his 300 grand and
then he gets another 300 grand nice
but because he's tom he took his money
back and he's like i want to reinvest
that other 300 grand into something that
we all do together
and then like we all work together for a
while we did some really interesting
things we like
produced a feature film we did a bunch
of successful good things but ultimately
like
his other businesses kind of pulled him
away from that my brother van
moved out to los angeles and then i was
kind of left in new york i didn't really
want to run this big company
so it kind of petered out but like it's
like he's one of those people that you
look back at your life you're like who
are the people who stepped in and had
like a
dramatic [ __ ] impact on my life and
he's one of those people
right and the the guy who uh
reminds me of that kind of the same way
when you're working in the art gallery
and it and you show him a video like
you're filming the guy's art and he's
like oh let me see it
you were like legitimately scared he was
gonna chew you out yeah
and he was like wow it's kind of like
when i stole my dad's video camera that
he won in a
golf tournament i i made a video and i
was like hey dad
check this out he says how did you make
this i told him well i stole your camera
and he was like
[ __ ] way to go that's cool i mean
like
you know my older son now is 23 and like
when i think about my kids like
to discover that they have a passion
that they're so excited about that they
feel like they have to
steal like i couldn't imagine being
anything but supportive about that sure
and like i definitely like a big part of
like the success that my brother van and
i were able to find in our filmmaking
career
is because like we're really lucky to
meet people who recognize that
we saw a kind of passion enthusiasm and
then like stepped up to support that
so when you go into youtube in 2010
after having an hbo series after having
like the first
world's first viral video do you feel
like
in in part like because i felt this way
after making jackass movies
and then going to youtube like [ __ ]
you know i've done these big things and
now i'm
like this is the most like demoralizing
demotion now i'm going to
upload youtube videos and like all right
did you have any of that you know i
really think getting on youtube was the
smartest move i ever made man because my
life is really good today as a result
and you know what i've been enjoying is
camping out with my bros
and sitting around a fire it's that time
of year man
and i got this new fire pit that i am
absolutely in love with from a company
called
solo stove and this thing is so
portable i put it right in the little
cargo box on the back of my
rv pull it out all the time man i think
in the last
two weeks i've like had four different
nights with
big bonfires burning up pallets from our
new warehouse
oh man i love it i want you to try it
because it just lights fire
so easily it's virtually smokeless
it's got these holes which let air flow
through
man it's the best and i've been having a
great time and i want you to try it
plus if you do this you'll get a free
stand for the thing okay
you go to solostove.com and use the
promo code steve oh
again you're gonna get a free stand for
any fire pit that you select and there's
a great selection
i'm telling you you're gonna love this
thing i'm using it all the time
so get yourself ones at solostove.com
with the promo code stevo and enjoy the
free stand that comes with it
now let's hear about getting on youtube
i mean ultimately it turned out for me
to be the best thing in the world
because that's the way
that the world is now and to have kind
of gotten on that wave
like you know back in 2013 for me
it revolutionized my whole career and
it's singularly why i'm
like really doing pretty well for myself
today but it was
i had to swallow a pill to do that yeah
i mean there was like for me it was a
little bit more
like it wasn't that one click moment
decision point it was like
a bunch of [ __ ] up [ __ ] happened that
drove me to it
you know so like hbo said no to a second
season which was like okay we saw that
coming a mile away
show had no business being on hbo in the
first place i mean
like my hbo show is just nothing but
like a [ __ ] up youtube vlog but on hbo
before youtube vlogs worth it if i
understood
what i learned about that correctly it
was like
highly critically praised but just
didn't get the numbers
yeah and look with it they put it on
midnight on friday night so who knows
what it would have done if it had been
on at a time when people could actually
access it
um it did really well from a review
perspective but also it didn't look like
an hbo show and that i understand like
hbo everything's so
like this is when they were pushing out
like [ __ ] sopranos was coming to an
end game of thrones was just on the
horizon
and then here's this stupid tv show that
we filmed on like 80 dollar cameras from
walmart
about us like running around new york
and doing silly things and
i get why it didn't work for hbo but so
they said no
and then i took like a couple years and
i like developed this new show idea
and i pitched really hard i pitched it
to a bunch of people mtv was sort of
close
but i remember like in the end mtv was
like look
we think that this is amazing really
amazing but we're not sure it works for
tv
maybe we could put it on our website and
i just remember being like
you [ __ ] like i took such
offense at that so like
some other things transpired but
ultimately like that show that mtv said
no to that
show that i wanted to make was what
became my
youtube vlog which like at its height
was doing more views in any 24-hour
period than like
every viacom channel combined i bet yeah
and it didn't start out the youtube
initiative as a vlogging thing it was
more like
shorts and you know like yeah no it took
five years for me to get my first
400 000 subscribers in five years i got
400 000 subscribers
and that was when you started vlogging
it was 2015. daily vlogging that's right
and daily vlogging like i went from 400
000 to 10 million
in like 18 months okay i gotta ask about
this because i know that you were really
sort of uh
not reluctant but but maybe you had some
just trepidation about oh like what this
is going to represent as an
like obligation as it like the amount of
work and you know i'm going to lose my
mind like
and then you said i [ __ ] i'm going to
do it like i'm terrified
from a creative perspective like i i
feel like
when i got on youtube i thought i was
like you know what i'm only going to put
out the most quality [ __ ] i want to be
like the quentin tarantino
of youtube i wanted that i want to be
the [ __ ] quentin tarantino where
when i upload a youtube video at the the
[ __ ]
internet the internet rejoices but then
like it became just sort of crushing
to unders to realize wait how backwards
the the youtube
consumption mentality is that like
they're only going to reward
repetition and and and quantity over
quality and i just like thought
[ __ ] man i've never been able to bring
myself to
like i tried it a little bit but but
just like from a creative standpoint i
can't put something up every day
and i know that for you from a creative
standpoint from like
you're like the the cinematographer like
the [ __ ]
you know the scorsese of vlogs
i can only imagine how much you lost
your mind
yeah you know it's it it's a tricky
thing because i think that there's like
the technical aspects the algorithm what
youtube rewards what youtube wants
there's all of that and i think people
put a lot of
emphasis on that and i think that that's
incorrect i think that that is
absolutely a part of it
i think it's like 10 of it i think the
other 90 is human behavior
and so like i wasn't successful
because technically i was consistent i
think that the success came from the
much more human relationship that like
being a part of someone's life every
single
day and and who was editing all of these
that wasn't me oh my gosh how long did
it take you
to edit a video so it's typically like
i got it down to about a half an hour a
minute but it started at an
hour a minute so for an eight minute
vlog it'd be eight hours of editing and
in the end it was a little bit closer to
like
half that every day every day seven i
think i did 800 episodes without missing
one or something like that you moved
that you moved out of new york you're so
frazzled
that i mean that was in two two
different bursts right there was the
personal vlogging and then there was the
vlogging as
the company yeah i mean sort of it was
just basically like
i think there was like three or four
different framings of the vlogs where
like i quit with like a big enthusiastic
[ __ ] you youtube i'm out of here and
then like three hours later like
crawling back in being like you know
what actually i'm gonna start the vlog
again
i i just couldn't turn it off like i was
so
when you when you have that level of
cadence
like you are so completely at least i
was so completely enveloped in it where
it was like
the tail was wagging the dog a hundred
percent
like i had no idea what my actual life
was or who i actually was i only
understood
myself as this character and like you
would live
every moment of your life like i can
like if i put myself there now it's like
okay let me think what did i do today i
woke up
act one was like arguing with candace
and then i went for a run
and then like act act one ends in this
drive
going from my house in santa monica to
manhattan beach act two
is like i meet meet you outside your
vans demo and like we say what's up we
chat about the van
and like act two would sort of end with
like us sitting down for this podcast
act three would be us surfing get all
the shots need some dialogue gotta get a
gopro out there with us
then like the episode would end with me
sort of going home and then boom i need
a little bit of me at the house with the
family to humanize the episode
so i gotta capture that before it's dark
because at night like it doesn't look
right
okay and then that's it and then like
even if i'm pretending to be there and
be present and have family like family
hour with my family
all i'm thinking about is that edit i'm
writing it in my head okay i got more
shots than i needed for that first act i
don't need to lean into the running so
much i did that yesterday the audience
is going to get bored
i'm going to give 20 seconds of running
tops and i'm going to include that one
line i filmed into my camera when i
stepped on like a [ __ ] needle like
that's the level of like madness that
your brain be sure
and it becomes entirely monolithic like
i couldn't think about anything else
when people would be like hey can we get
breakfast someday i'd be like
i don't think they're gonna know what to
do if i point a camera at him i'm like
i'm sorry i can't
i can't meet you it's like lunch i'm
like sorry coffee it's like i literally
will not meet you you're not in the
scene i'm serious like
if it was a person who like i couldn't
make an hour to work with for my
video i just didn't meet people right
and when people would be like look let's
get together and catch up i'd be like
how [ __ ] dare you how dare you
when someone's like yo let's go grab a
drink i'm like are you [ __ ]
nuts like first of all like by the time
it's dark time those are edit hours
second of all a drink might [ __ ] up my
brain enough or i'll not be able to edit
on time
like how dare you and it became like
that's what i became like i became a
monster
and yeah and turning that off was really
hard because
the crazier i got the more it was sort
of rewarded
the more success i found sure i mean
paul and i we uh edit all my videos
and and i think that like we can
intimately relate to the
the psychotic like like writing and
producing in our heads and
this and that and like we have if we
collaborate
collaborate on that i don't know how you
do that
all by yourself and every single day so
yeah 800 videos daily vlogs
yeah the first burst was 500
every day yeah which is 18 months
it's [ __ ] insane so then they said
now i'm going to get to the question
that i've just been dying to ask
and you know apologies if it's uh
if it's rude but you create this
this platform called beam which was uh
sort of snapchat before snapchat
and uh you know and it kind of
went it evolved through like sort of
different kind of iterations of what it
was
um you sold it to cnn
for an estimated 25 million dollars
and then you referred to
its uh ultimate demise as taking an
l and my question is how the [ __ ] do you
sell a hot cake for 25 million bucks
and then that's an l
it was an l for a couple reasons it was
an l because it wasn't a billion
okay it was an l because so much of my
team like when when so what's
first of all let me just let me give
this podcast like a [ __ ]
you guys this is like an exclusive here
this is the first time
someone's asked me about beam really
since my
nda expired wow
you know this is about to get real juicy
but let me ask you
do you have a butthole you do don't you
and sometimes you take big sloppy poops
right out of it huh
well when you do that why would you just
wipe it around with dry toilet paper
when you could
wash it properly with a bidet
from hello tushy this is my favorite
product that i've ever promoted on this
podcast
ladies and gentlemen it is so refreshing
to get done taking a big
dump and then just twist the knob
on the hellotushy bidet and blah
it just blasts your butthole with a
refreshing
clean spray of water and then
you grab the toilet paper and when you
give it that
wet wipe it's so just wonderful and you
look at the toilet paper and there's not
even any poop on it because you've
cleaned your butthole properly if you
don't already have this you're out of
your
mind but the good news is i'm going to
give you a deal on it
you go to hellotushy.como
and you get 10 off your order plus
free shipping man don't walk around with
a poopy butthole anymore
use the bidet from hello tushy and clean
it properly because it feels
so good so one more time for 10
off your order and free shipping go to
hellotushy.com
stevo now let's get this juicy first
scoop
wow not that i'm sitting on any secrets
like an open book in fact like
it's so fun i can talk about this now
but like there were three different
occasions over the course of that
four-year contract where like cnn called
my like
people and they're like yeah casey's
talking about [ __ ] he's not allowed to
talk about and my agent would have to
call and be like hey dude
you gotta shut the [ __ ] up and i'm like
[ __ ] i'm sorry like i'm incapable
of yeah like i'm just like that's just
the kind of guy i am sure when did your
nba expire
i want to say it was four years four
years after the deal was signed so like
last may or something like that might
have been three years but
to answer your question like you know i
started a tech company because i was
really excited about the idea of
starting a tech company and i think we
had a great idea
for a product and you said snapchat
before snapchat
we were snapchat before snapchat but
then snapchat launched stories
and when they launched stories i was
like oh [ __ ] that's like what we're
building but
way better and they released it before
us
so like we were snapchat before snapchat
but we were also snapchat
later to market and we weren't as good
it's like look snapchat look snapchat
users i know you love your product and i
know it's great but we've got something
worse for you
just give us a few more months
just be patient right if you'll be
patient we'll get you something even
worse
um back now you'll play twice as much
exactly
no i think we like we had an amazing
team and we did have something that was
really compelling like the thesis of
that app was amazing it was like not
about filters it's just
about sort of sharing the real world
around you and i think a lot of people
spoke to that and i think since then
we've seen other apps be successful
because they represent some version of
that like people yearn for the
truth when everything is like [ __ ]
face shaping filters and stuff like you
just want some reality
so we had a great product and cnn's
enthusiasm i think was
naively i didn't realize how much it was
for my reach
and my success right you know like i
really pushed them hard and like the
original pitch came
because jeff zucker the cnn
boss who i think just recently stepped
down he was a great guy and a wonderful
experience with him but i met with him
and he's like
what do i have to do to get you to come
over to cnn and i was like nothing i
don't
there's nothing cnn has that i'm
interested in i love being on youtube
and i was like but your tech sucks like
your app sucks like your technology is
garbage um i was like you should buy my
tech company and we should build stuff
together and
that's where it came from and that's
what they bought they bought my tech
company they kept every employee on
and i was really excited about building
technology with them
and i think that ultimately like a big
company like that they've got like
shareholders and all kinds of [ __ ] that
has a nimble startup you don't have to
confront
they need to make money they have to
show how we're making money
so the kind of company that i like to
build which is like give us three years
to figure out exactly who we are and how
we're gonna make this work
was like no no we need profits in six
months sort of thing like we need
revenue in six months
here's how we have to and it wasn't they
weren't wrong or unfair to
ask that or to expect that but i think
that it was a misalignment
to take like a really nimble tech
startup
that has sort of the mentality of of
entrepreneurs and founders
in trying to sort of force that round
peg into the square hole which is like a
you know whatever turner is a 50 year
old institution and that's where the
misalignment came from
and i think that they tried to save that
by
you know getting rid of my partner and i
after a year they fired matt and me
which was super amicable and the people
who did it did it right and it was a
great thing like
everyone at cnn was [ __ ] cool as [ __ ]
about it but then they brought my whole
team
internal and like i really that for me
was a big l
because like every single employee at
beam
was hired because like i vouched for
that company and like i felt like in
some part they were all there because of
me
um so you're saying that they let you
and matt go
but they sort of stole your no
almost the opposite like they let us all
go
and matt and i were really adamant about
like he can't shut this you can't fire
the team and they're really
forceful about the fact we're keeping
the whole team together we're bringing
everybody in
so you were stroked on that sort of
what i wasn't soaked on like it was like
a it was like a
it was nice that everybody wasn't losing
their job it was shitty because
everybody signed up to work for a cool
ass startup
and now everybody literally has to check
in and go into this gigantic building
in midtown and work at cnn and then like
shortly thereafter like you know matt
and i
had no part of the company we weren't
like
really supposed to be interacting with
our former employees at all
but you know you start hearing stories
and people are unhappy and people start
leaving and then they broke up this team
and
this team's not working out and this
person could keep their job if they move
so they didn't keep their
it just sort of fell apart and like the
money the paycheck
[ __ ] yeah like big success i couldn't be
more excited about that
every founding member of the company
before the acquisition got paid
my personal assistant like a kid who's
like 22 out of college and like
his job was like make sure the studio
lights were always on and like deal with
admin [ __ ] like
he got like a the kind of check where
you could buy like a very decent house
and we made sure of that like everybody
vests a hundred percent
day one like we fought for the team but
in the end like i
really and i still to this day like
really feel like i let that team down
because like the success of that company
would have succeeded because of me and
its failure was it failed because of me
so i can i can have a litany of excuses
of why cnn made it really hard to
succeed
i think it's all [ __ ] in the end
like if i still should have been able to
figure out how to navigate that and find
success and i didn't
so in the end the l is the company
culture and like
sort of this exciting thing about
working for a tech startup just got lost
because now those people work for cnn i
think that's a nuanced way of getting
into i think the
l for me was about integrity like i
didn't feel like i could walk away with
my head high
just because i got a really dope
paycheck that's crazy because um
you know we were talking to mark cuban a
couple weeks ago
and his whole thing was uh in the
dot-com
bubble he sold his company to yahoo
and like right before the bubble burst
he got millions of dollars and then like
almost immediately after the transaction
what he sold for millions of dollars
was like completely worthless i think he
was
closer to billions i think you're right
i think you're right i think it might
have actually been billion yeah is it
300 million or something like that yeah
but
it's it's uh you know ever since then i
think it's it's
you know hailed as like the best
business move ever that mark cuban made
the best business move for him right
in unloading this this company before it
became totally worthless
and i think that that that's you know on
some level very comparable to what you
did with beam
because it never even really you know
like exploded in the first place
and like you were able to sell it for
like
arguably more than it was worth and and
you unloaded it and then it
kind of went away so like to me that's
just
like i think it all comes down to
what's the end game like what is how do
you define success and if the definition
of success
is like get the [ __ ] bag then mark
cuban's the most successful guy in the
world if the success
if your definition of success is
something different from that then it's
you know then it's i think a little bit
more complicated and like my definition
of success for that company
was a little bit more than like you know
me getting that
cnn bag and like no regrets i'm very
proud of what we did
like like one of the things i never talk
about
is the fact that like when you're like
the ceo and you're like the founder
you raise all this money you write like
once a month once every two months these
updates all of your investors
and they're formal and like truth be
told my partner matt
mostly wrote them and then sent them to
me and i would put them into my own
email and send them because i'm like
you know i can barely read and write
over here [ __ ] i just gotta drop
out get a d minus in 10th grade english
um
matt got college man that kid's smart
and
and then like so you have to send these
monthly updates like here's what we're
up to here's where we're struggling
here's where we're succeeding i just
stopped sending those because the
company was just doing
so poorly this is before cnn bought us
we were doing we were out of money we
were just
[ __ ] users were dropping off and i
just stopped sending those
and when you stop getting those that
means the company's going tits up and
then
six months later i got to i had to call
all the investors
every single investor on the list and i
was calling them to let them know
that we had sold the company and how big
their returns were
and that day to me like that is the
benchmark
of success all these people whether
they're just like
you know venture capitalists who are
only interested in return or they're
much more thoughtful people who are like
i believe in you casey and i want to
support you
they all looked at me and decided i
believe in this guy enough to write him
a check
and the fact that i was able to deliver
on that to every single person was a
huge deal
like to me yeah that is the that moment
was the ultimate success much more so
than the paycheck so
when you when i talk about like an l at
beam like
again i got that paycheck was great but
like if the paycheck had
a fraction of that but like we had built
something that to this day is still
thriving
and all those employees like went on to
bigger and better things or felt great
about what their contributions are
that would have like i'd sleep with a
bigger smile at night but how do you
know
the employees aren't thinking that right
now they might be but i know that like
in the year that in the years months
after we sold the company whether they
were working for us
under cnn or they're working directly at
cnn under a different boss
that it wasn't the same level of
enthusiasm
and satisfaction that it was working for
a nimble startup or actually a part of
something that
that is kind of your own that you have a
kind of ownership over because they all
had a bunch of bar codes on their necks
scott
okay scott it's also it's also like
in that spit space and i haven't had a
i've been out of the tech game for five
years now but like
then and i'm sure it's the same way now
like mobile app developers that can deal
in video
are the most sought after programmers
out there like they're they're so
exclusive we had to talk
a lot of our employees into moving to
new york from the west coast where they
live
like every single one of them could have
left working for us on a monday
and gone and gotten 3x the paycheck on a
tuesday from
from facebook which was just 12 blocks
north from us
like they could every one of them could
have done that and every one of them
said no i love this company i believe in
these guys i love matt i love casey
i want to be a part of what they're
building and like the fact that i wasn't
able to deliver on that like
that sucks that sucks these are people
that are all [ __ ] smarter than me and
cape
more capable than me and that have like
built their careers out and like
that's part of their gamble too they
knew they were taking your chance
but like man what i have loved for those
every one of those people who took a
chance on me for me to be able to just
like
give them those kind of dividends i was
able to give those investors
do you have another startup in you i
don't
know i mean that's like a it's like a
much bigger conversation which is like
you know now i'm sort of confronted with
this fact that i'm 40 years old
and i've got money which is weird i'm
just like you know used to be on welfare
now i've got money
and like i don't need to work for money
right now
so therefore like where's the motivation
and if you like dig deep enough in
yourself like where i've landed is like
i can either go work for money or just
like hang out with my two-year-old
so like today she and i like played in
the garden and like
tried not to prick our fingers on roses
and then we ate like
candy that was way more fun than
starting a company
so yeah so like that's kind of where i
am right now is like
i don't know when you're faced with the
question of like you can do whatever you
want today what do you want to do
every day for me it's like i want to
play with my kids and go surfing
yeah rightly probably just do that until
you don't want to do that anymore well
that's like that's where we you know
come back to new york city
how how often are you uploading youtube
videos never
never never never i've uploaded once in
the last five months
all right well let me ask you this how
much was that ethiod plane ticket
it's the most expensive plane ticket in
the world 50 grand
unbelievable but like the whole story
i i started watching like i got to the
video so i didn't want to
did you say how much it was on the video
i might have
i don't remember but it three room
suite on the plane an airplane
and and where you're flying to [ __ ] abu
dhabi
you like palm springs
um so it goes like this so how do you
get those dudes so i've always been
obsessed with like
first class yeah because i spent the
first like 10 years of my
real career where i was traveling
non-stop whatever's cheapest
middle seats in the back or whatever the
shittiest airline is that's what i fly
and like the more you pass by those
seats up front you start to get a little
obsessed
i went through all of these like
different versions of obsession like
finally figured out how to almost always
fly first without ever paying for it
that was like mid-2000s casey where i
didn't have any money but i got really
good at faking it
wow and then like and i started to find
success and
i'm still sort of obsessed with flying
even though i don't get on planes
anymore
but what happened was i think it was
youtube at the height of my daily
vlogging youtube said
come be a speaker at our brand cast like
our annual summit
in australia and i said i can't it's a
two-day flight and i need to make a
daily vlog
and i was like i'll tell you what if you
fly me through dubai so i can go on this
fancy plane
i can make videos about the flight
they're like sure no problem
except for they bought me a [ __ ]
business class ticket
not first class and i was like okay i'll
just like two bedrooms instead of things
well that was the thing
it's like they like sent me business
classes like [ __ ] i said first and then
like
i was like wow they spent like 10 grand
on this ticket and i was like i'm not
gonna say anything like i can't complain
like who the [ __ ] am i
so i made the video about flying their
business class and it was like fine
and people watched the video and stuff
i'm flying back also business class
the airline pulls me aside they had seen
my video
and they wanted me to try out their
first class experience
that's how i got the free [ __ ] first
class on the flight so does that mean
you had to turn around and go back
after your return
no it was a flight from dubai back
that's right so i'm fine
i'm flying back from the states like my
return flight they saw it when i was in
australia
right because i'm uploading like i shoot
the video today
they grabbed you they grabbed you on
your connection
in dubai literally like going down the
run going down the street and i got all
my cameras
i'm talking to myself i'm like excuse me
mr nyston i was like [ __ ] please don't
say i can't film on this flight please
don't say it
and they're like we've been we're able
to upgrade you to first class and i'm
like me
this is like all this is like a
culmination of every dream i've ever had
so that's what happened then i made that
video and that video did like 70 million
views
so that immediately after that like i
don't know six months later
or something like that same airline that
airlines called
what's it called no emirates i'm not
even at et hot yet
emirates announces some new first class
situation everybody on youtube
twitter is like casey you should check
this one out and sure enough like
they reach out and they're like hey you
want to try our new first and i was like
i do
i do so they're like we only fly from
zurich though and i was like oh i've got
no plans to be in switzerland like who
the [ __ ] am i some international like
banker man of mystery and they're like
we'll bring you to switzerland
and i was like great i'll go to
switzerland i'll ski so they
flew me in their plane i remember
getting on that plane and i was like
they're showing me all the first class
cabins and no one's in them
and i'm like whoa when do you board the
rest of flight and they're like no we
haven't actually launched this yet
you're the only person in this cabin and
i was like oh
whoa okay so that was number two then we
get to the ultimate which is this etihad
it's called like the apartment because
you get three rooms you get a bedroom
you get a bathroom with a shower in it
and then you get a living room with a
big screen tv and then you get a hallway
which connects all of
them it's bigger than this without a
doubt square footage-wise it's bigger
than this van that we're in right
bigger than my studio in marina del rey
it's [ __ ] huge
and the difference was they paid me for
that like that was a
paid job and the thing is had they
offered me the job without the paycheck
i would have said yes
if they had offered me the job for a
discounted ticket price
i would have paid them to get on that
plane
and they flew me in like i was like you
know very
sort of meek about it but i was like you
know i'm vegan if there's if there are
any options
i get on the plane they have this menu
and like my name is embossed in the lev
leather cover and it's like menu
a la casey neistat and then in
parentheses everything's vegan
and it was like options vegan options
like
six of them and then they just brought
me everything on the menu because they
had made it all for me like it was so
insane
wow and then like you get in the bed and
like i was so overwhelmed by the idea
that i'm laying in a bed
on an airplane that i wasn't able to
sleep like it was just too exciting
it's just like the shower like how the
shower works there's literally a
timer it goes from green to red
but like i think i had six minutes of
showering but six minutes of showering
is also three
two minute showers so i broke those
showers
i was showering the whole flight home no
that was really exciting but like
that video did you know 30 million views
or something so i
i don't know what how i don't know how
to equate that value but you have to
imagine that it was a much better deal
for the airline
how do you make a commercial that gets a
10-minute commercial
that gets 30 million views for the price
of a stupid ticket
right [ __ ] amazing dude how that's so
fortunate
you became the like the first class guy
you know like what a great lane to
be in you know what's what's crazy is
that prior to becoming that guy i
remember watching
all of these first class videos because
i was obsessed with it
and i'm like all these videos sucks but
they have crazy views because anyone
who's ever been on an airplane is forced
to walk by
they'll see you're like god i wish i
knew everything about those seats and i
was like if i ever get the opportunity
i'm gonna go ape [ __ ]
and i had like this list in my head of
what's wrong with every airline review
and it's like the camera's too narrow so
it looks tiny it's claustrophobic and
the lighting's terrible
so like on those flights i requested
like i made sure it's a day flight
so the lighting would be good lighting's
everything dark on an airplane does not
work i tried to do it i made a couple
videos where it's dark it looks gross
and then like all these it has to be on
a tripod you can't hand hold the camera
on an airplane there's too much action
if the camera isn't fixed you're
stressed out when you're trying to watch
it
you can't see what you're looking at so
like get that shot like all of this [ __ ]
i obsessed over
and if you go back and watch any of
those videos you realize that like
every shot like that etihad no emirates
playing that i was the only person in
the first class cabin
i was the first person to fly in that
cabin and i did major damage
so i was like breaking through the
ceiling panels so i could mount a camera
up there
and i did that in all these different
locations like i was trying to be as
respectful as possible but i was like
the shot's kind of more important than
me not scratching the wall here
and i would bet that they would agree
with that because that video did insane
views
for sure you know it's so good man
what's your favorite airline that's so
hard
um i mean
i like jet blue because they're nice
like those those um middle eastern
airlines are insanely nice but that's
like
that's like saying oh rolls-royce has
more comfortable seats than my honda and
it's like okay
but like my old toyota was the best car
i ever owned even though it's not as
fancy as a rolls-royce i don't
know rolls-royce i'm just trying to make
a bad analogy here i feel like i feel
like other parts of the world
besides america they really have the
customer service down at like a hotel
like good evening sir how are you
here how may i assist you like in japan
they bow to you and they
just want to accommodate your every
needs here they're just like [ __ ] it
what do you want
yeah it's unfortunate but like i think
like my
the hardest part of flying on planes is
like my wife right now is booking a trip
back east for this summer with the kids
and stuff and she's flying with her mom
i'm driving i'm literally going to drive
my truck from la to new york because i
don't want to fly
um not that i'm against it but like i've
had the opportunity to drive at much
better drive
it's tough man with the [ __ ] masks on
the plane dude
it's so like the reason why i'm i'm i
have such like anxiety about flying it's
not because of like i'm worried about
getting sick i have my vaccine
i'm not worried it's everybody else like
it's that guy that yells at that lady
for not wearing her mask like i don't
want to be around that energy
yeah you're like stuck in this tube 30
000 feet in the sky with like
200 people and like if any percent of
them are angry at any other percentage
of them like i don't want to be a part
of that
and that [ __ ] stress it freaks me out
wow
yeah yeah dude have you always been like
that just like
be careful the energy you hang out with
no i've definitely gotten super weird as
i've gotten older
yeah i mean i think there's a way to
sort of
sum up casey the way he's always been i
think it's just one word it's just
hustle you know yeah well i'm trying to
turn that off stevo
yeah actually i'm curious about that so
with turning off this
like stopping the daily vlogging to
reset your brain to just be in the world
and not be thinking about a vlog all the
time
like how long is that transition and
were there some things that like
surfing where it's like you do it
because you love it you're not even
filming were there some things where
you're like
oh wow i actually like doing this
because now i'm not filming it but i'm
still doing it like oh i didn't even
realize i actually really like this one
thing
you know yeah like my wife is a good
example of that
i'm not even joking i'm totally [ __ ]
serious
like spending time with her but no we
were on the
like verge of divorce the entire
vlog chapter of my life like right on
the edge of divorce
and i would do everything i could to
appease her and i do mean appease
because i didn't i wasn't invested in
like fixing the relationship or anything
like that i just needed her to like
not be pissed at me for today so i could
put her in the vlog
and that sounds like the most awful
thing but i'm just being honest like
that's literally what it was
and now like i like hanging out with her
like i tweeted after i quit vlogging
that like
been spending time with my wife turns
out she's pretty cool and like
everybody's like
lol haha and i'm like no i'm [ __ ]
totally serious and so stuff like that
socializing
like i never socialized like i literally
cut every friend out of my
life out of my life unless they were
good on camera
because like i don't have time to hang
out with friends like i need to make
content
i agree with that completely and i mean
no no just like you know the idea
there's certain people
they're like hey you know let's hang out
and and it's not a question of whether
they're good on camera
it's just like i i'm
on this planet i'm i'm in this
body like to make [ __ ] happen
and like if if a person isn't
contributing to like
me accomplishing some kind of a goal
that matters to me
then [ __ ] no i don't want to chat over
dinner
you know it's not about being on camera
it's just about being like
goal-oriented it's unproductive
yeah yeah i have no interest in a
conversation
or spending time socializing because
that doesn't that doesn't
advance uh our [ __ ]
objective a goal is that something you
ever hope to turn off or you're just
riding it
you know what i mean like i feel so
strongly about that
and then but but the difference is like
with my with my girl i'm in a
relationship with lux
and like like man like with you guys
like we don't have to be working i love
being around you guys
yeah but i do not want to bring more
people into that circle
i just don't have any interest in that i
only want to work seven days a week for
the rest of my entire day scott and i
both
i'm so different from you guys we talked
about that
i got a vasectomy because i'm so sure
that i don't want to happen i appreciate
that
i just like working so much that like
that's all i want to do
because i think that's how i get my
validation but i also enjoy it
and like people are like dude you want
to hang out you know go to a restaurant
i'm like
i'm in bed by like 8 39 so i can wake up
at like four or five to field
new york emails or like there's a guy in
australia that we like i
enjoy the [ __ ] out of that and i only
want to do that
yeah so i think that that's the answer
it's like you got to figure out what you
love
doing and there's a couple of things
that i always subscribe to
really like emphatically very
consciously um
one of which is like i my goal in life
is to do
only exactly what i want to do at any
given time like there's this woody
guthrie
quote that maybe bob dylan or somebody
like that stole
but it goes like the definition of
success is to wake up in the morning go
to bed at night and in between do what
you want to do
i think he said the definition of
freedom is to wake up at night go to
wake up in the morning go to bed at
night in between do what you want to do
and to me it's kind of my ultimate so
like that hustle
especially that hustle that like i
really promoted and
glorified and romanticized in like my
vlog and everything that i represented
like you're doing these ted talk looking
things oh yeah like it never said no to
anything i was just going
like 10 jobs and i love you he said like
here's why i am here
i want to be and in between that is just
a whole bunch of work
when i when i see you say that i'm like
[ __ ] yeah there is
but you you have how many subscribers on
youtube to almost 12 million now
sorry so so would you have the same
mentality of like well i
only want to do what i want to do if you
had like 50 000 or no and that's right
that's what i'm driving towards is like
this clarity that i've always had in my
life in the last video i made in new
york city
where where i actually move out to
california like i talk about this
i was so aware that like that hustle
was a sprint for me like i'm a big
runner i used to be a competitive
endurance runner like i said literally
compete
and you get your sprints and then you've
got like your longer races and like
i was competitive in triathlons at
sprint distance i would win those but
the iron man's 140 mile race my only
objective
was to finish confidently so therefore
like it's about pacing and about being
smart
i always understood like the hustle part
of my life the new york city chapter
like that
whether it was being my startup whether
it was a startup i had before that the
startup i had before that whether it's
my hbo series my youtube series
that was a [ __ ] sprint and the finish
line at the end of that is like if i can
get across this finish
line i want a wife i want kids and i
want to chill the [ __ ] out
and i want to effectively retire when i
start my family
and that was the dream and it was like
that came from an amalgam of things like
one was the fact that like when i had my
first
kid i was 16 years old and like i tried
to be the best dad i could but like
i'm 16 and i'm getting [ __ ] free milk
and diapers from the state because i
can't afford to buy my kid
milk or diapers like you try but i knew
that i wasn't
the dad that i i could have been because
i had all these limitations around me
so i always had this idea that like i
will sprint until i can get to a place
where i can just [ __ ] chill out
my dad was like i talked to him
yesterday he's still working you know
he's barely retired and he's
70 almost and like i never remember
anything from my childhood but him
working
so that was what leaving new york was
like that last year in new york where i
said i was miserable because i wanted to
do what i'm doing now which is just that
like
i i have the money like i got that
[ __ ] bag like i i got the youtube
subscriber like i did everything i
wanted to do they're all ticked off the
list
the thing that's on the list right now
that's next up is like
really just like chilling out doing what
i want to do enjoying my life and like
spending time with my family and the
privilege that that is is not lost on me
like to say that even out loud i'm
uncomfortable admitting
that i get to have that life because who
the [ __ ] i'm 40 years old
yeah who the [ __ ] gets to have that at
40. who my dad
literally retired six months ago and he
still doesn't have that
like he's trying to find a part-time job
right now and he's like it'll just make
things a little bit easier
like he doesn't have that and he's
staring at his twilight years like
i have that right now like i'm totally
[ __ ] healthy and fit there's nothing
wrong with me
my wife's still hot like we're still
young like and i have that that's insane
that's [ __ ] insane so to not hit the
brakes and be like i [ __ ] did that
yeah but to have something which is like
no now's the time to hustle it's like no
[ __ ] i got
nothing left to prove and what's crazy
is like
for me i'm such a like a guy of extremes
i'm so
scared of like fame right now like i'm
so relaxed part of the reason why i'm
struggling to make youtube's videos
right now is like
i don't want to put myself out there i
don't want to be recognized i don't want
people to talk to me i don't want people
to look at me anymore
like i did that that was cool i tried it
i got to try fame
fame is amazing right no one's trading
it in
no one's trading it but like but like an
answer dude
i just wanted to try it and like i got
to try it like i got to be like a
somewhat famous like c-level celebrity
for a minute
and i i didn't really like okay let's
turn that off and it's like it kind of
bumped me out that i don't know how to
turn that off besides like
trying not to further it but like i got
to try that and that's really special
i got to know what it's like to run a
company i got to do all these things
like
i just need to appreciate that because i
don't know if like
maintaining that cadence is is i do know
that it's just not interesting to me
right now yeah cool
what's that big dude sorry to cut you
off i know you're gonna say something
but i was
there's a guy in like the 30s he
interviewed like
all the billionaires of the day and he
they asked him what the definition of
success was and it was peace of mind
yeah i always liked that you know
because no matter he's like
no matter how rich these people were
like back in the day
he's like they literally almost lost
their mind at the end of their life
trying to figure out what to do with
their money and give it away to
different organ organizations or people
that it wouldn't kill them
because it's just so much for somebody
to handle you know
yeah what's up dale day-lewis um there
will be blood yeah
yeah this literally the [ __ ] movie is
that in this guy's pursuit
of money or his ver all the only version
of success that he understood
he lost everything every person that was
close to him his family his son his
partners his friends
everything and the movie literally ends
with him
sitting by himself over a dead body and
he looks to the camera and says
i'm finished and like
there's not like that's not that far of
a [ __ ] abstraction like they're
that's real
you drink their milkshake dude to kindly
i drank your milkshake
to like constantly be gut-checking how
do i
define success right now like
that ted talk you're talking about i
defined success then really acutely
because it was something to
for me success right now is like can i
be a good dad can i be a good husband
and can i be present
and that's such like a wishy-washy
[ __ ] new age stupid thing to say
but like i never got to do that and i
look back at those hustle years that
like
i'm so guilty of romanticizing and like
the reality was like there's a lot of
glory the glory is all anybody saw
including me
but the reality of the day-to-day was
[ __ ] misery
it was shutting out anyone like you want
to have a conversation with me i'll look
you in the eye and nod my head
all i'm thinking about is how the [ __ ]
is that
that's all it was it was completely
artificial
it's interesting and i i don't i don't
need to like get go uh
often a big thing but for me probably
the most uncomfortable question
is are you happy you know and it's
probably like the definition of success
is to be happy yeah
and when people ask me if i am happy i
think
for many many years i it just made me
uncomfortable every
like uh you know but then i realize what
my answer is
and the answer is no i'm not [ __ ]
happy because what the
what's that gonna get me like content
content
and i'm gonna [ __ ] like stop like lay
down like oh i don't need to do anymore
you're like
[ __ ] no like i'm i'm so grateful that
i'm not happy because that's the
that's the drive that's the fire under
my ass i'm not i never want to be
[ __ ] happy
[ __ ] happy he's about to drink
everybody's milkshake
and and uh you know i i love that that
you're so
you know serious about this you know
like that you are content
then i just want to chill and maybe i
can get there one day but uh well
that's why the first question i had was
like you guys have kids is because i
think it
kids aren't for everybody believe me not
entirely sure my mother should have had
kids
thanks mom i appreciate it but if we
could go back and do it over again maybe
skip the whole kids thing
um that said like when you have kids
there's oh my god there's an instant and
in that instant for the first time in
your whole [ __ ] life
your priority is no longer yourself like
i don't care how much you love other
people how much you love
you know relationships anything you have
in your life
there's nothing that can sort of fill
that void that is like you are literally
responsible for this
human that you created that is
completely [ __ ] vulnerable you're a
hundred percent on the hook
and that shifts your thinking so i i
think steve
like the reason why i can
[Music]
so aggressively pursue a kind of
contentment or happiness
is only because i have these this lens
to look through and it's the lens of
like these
these three kids that i have i mean if
only every parent felt that way
i don't think they have the luxury i
think most have to work and like deal
with reality is that i'm just
really lucky to have [ __ ] manipulated
their life around
and i i think that there's there are two
a lot of parents that just don't see it
or
they just you know remain so
self-absorbed and not
like you know they're just shitty
parents and you know like yeah i think
you should you have to get a license to
catch a fish i think you should have to
get a license to
become a [ __ ] parent but you don't
and what are you gonna do it's
making a baby is so easy it takes me
like 15 seconds
yeah it tops but dude you know if we've
been going forever we should
probably serve um i i just wanted to say
you know as sort of an overview um you
just want me to kiss your ass a little
bit i
admire you dude i i i admire
the spirit of everything that you've
done and and
i really feel that the spirit
overall is there's such a positivity
and and what's unique to you
and your spirit is that the positivity
is authentic
and i say that with just such
disgust for all of the for all of the
artificial
well let me get the views and the likes
and by saying
hey you can do anything that you put
your mind all of this
[ __ ] artificial positivity just makes
my
stomach turn so much and and you know
the old scene actions speak louder than
words you know like
when uh when you're doing your ted talk
and you're talking about like
hustling and like i say yes to
everything and if it involves a camera
like i'm in and like
just that all of that man like i just
see the
that there's actions behind like your
positivity that is not artificial that
it's authentic
and now like here you are like evolving
you know like you're not you say like oh
that's
that was me during my new york phase
that was when all these dudes
and it's great that you can evolve
through your phases and be authentic
and it's a [ __ ] honor to know you
dude i appreciate that they're very kind
words from you stevo
yeah rob i mean it [ __ ] yeah all right
dude let's [ __ ] surf let's do it
thanks that's good dude
what a cool dude and let me tell you
he's a rad surfer too man we paddled out
right after that
and i did not catch a single wave and he
was just catching them all over the
place
riding them all dude it was really
pretty impressive
and uh i was inspired as well so
very shortly after uh getting out of the
water and
so i came up with the idea what if i did
a daily vlog between now and
roughly when jackass 4 comes out i mean
so i reached out to somebody who i had
in mind and said
you want a job and they said yep so it
looks like i might
actually try it dude i might actually
try it and why not man
get inspired by guests like i said i got
that nft going man
you can you can check it out
life is good man all right